AMY LARKIN: Thank you.
It's such a pleasure
to be here.
I'm going to talk today about
the rules of business and the
laws of nature.
They are in direct
collision today.
We all know about the
financial ledger--
profit and loss--
know that since we're kids.
But there's another piece
of the financial ledger.
And that's cause and effect,
which we never talk about.
Every financial transaction has
an environmental impact.
And the environment is embedded
in every financial
transaction.
The financial and environmental
crises are
connected both in causes
and solutions.
What do I mean by that?
Well, do you remember the floods
in Thailand in 2011?
Yes?
Everyone?
It was a devastating effect
for Thailand.
And there was a terrible
typhoon.
But the real cause of the
catastrophe was the fact that
15 to 20 years before, in the
late '80s and '90s, there was
massive deforestation
in Thailand.
And so there was
no ground soil.
The topsoil had fallen down
mountains so that when this
huge typhoon hit, there was no
ground to hold the water.
So that would have
been bad enough.
But in fact, in Thailand
are factories
for Honda and Toyota.
And therefore factories that
were shut down for four to six
months did not have the parts
to supply to the other
factories for Honda and Toyota
in Kentucky, Singapore, and
the Philippines.
So in fact, there was economic
devastation in Kentucky,
Singapore, and the Philippines
from logging that happened 15
to 20 years earlier.
Toyota lost 3 and 1/2%
of its annual output.
And you and I paid unemployment
insurance for
workers in Kentucky because of
economic activity from 15 to
20 years earlier.
That's what I mean by the
financial and environmental
crises are connected.
I'm going to talk today
about three things.
The first is that environmental
damages can
bankrupt environmental systems,
ecosystems, as well
as financial systems.
The second is that
multinationals are playing a
truly surprising role
in the world.
I have been a Greenpeacer
for over 30 years.
And in the past 10 years, the
work that I have done with
multinationals has truly
shocked me off my feet.
I'll be talking a little
bit about that.
And then I'm going to talk about
Google's role in the
energy business.
Energy is not Google's
main business.
But Google is having a huge
impact on the energy business.
And I'm going to talk
about that.
So first thing is, I would like
to state what I think is
the first rule of business--
no nature, no business.
There's a growing understanding
of this in all
businesses.
This is the other change
in the weather.
In multinational boardrooms and
executive suites, I have
been drinking, dining, and
kvetching with executives over
problems they have from extreme
weather, from lost
commodities, from inability to
figure out their profit and
loss statements, to what's
going to happen with new
regulation.
There is a true growing
understanding that financial
health is based on environmental
health.
Governments not so much.
The corporations are
surprisingly way ahead of the
governments.
But the governments, for the
most part, are not connecting
Hurricanes Sandy, Katrina, and
Irene with a lack of good mass
transit or renewable
energy systems.
This is where the financial and
environmental crises have
not been connected in the
minds of government.
In many, many businesses,
they have.
In many, many businesses, they
haven't, especially those that
are in the fossil
fuel industry.
But this is the cause and effect
side of the ledger that
I was talking about.
But so here's what happens
actually when
business looks to nature.
Makani Power--
some of you here
probably know--
was recently bought by Google
a few weeks ago.
It is the most advanced
wind power technology.
It's in prototype now.
And it functions like a kite.
So it's tethered
to the ground.
And high above the air, the
wind turbines can move.
And high above the air, over
offshore where there are no
Kennedys to tell you
you cannot build an
offshore wind plant.
And it eliminates 90% of the
material used in conventional
wind turbines.
It is also a new technology that
would eliminate one of
the big problems with wind,
which is the intermittency,
when the wind doesn't blow.
Because, as we all know from
flying, when you're up there,
the wind is always blowing.
So in my mind, this is the
kind of business that can
actually accrue environmental
credit.
So I guess I should define
environmental debt, the
opposite of environmental
credit.
It's the polluting and damaging
actions that cost
other people real money like
those foresters, those
deforestation in Thailand from
20 years ago that cost Toyota
3 and 1/2% of its
output in 2011.
We cannot separate the
environmental system from the
financial system any more
than we can separate our
mind and our body.
They go together.
And that's just that.
And today, in the current
economy, these
connections are global.
So when the Mayans depleted
their water sources--
well, if you were in Europe or
China, you really didn't care.
It didn't affect your life.
It didn't affect your
environment.
Although I'm sure there are
some biologists and
environmentalists who
will tell me it did.
But basically, it was
not a felt problem.
But today, there are floods
in Pakistan, heat waves in
Ukraine, or droughts in the
Midwest United States.
And you are in business for
cotton, wheat, or corn--
or anything that uses
those commodities--
you're in big trouble.
This is, again, how the
financial and environmental
crises work together.
This extreme weather has meant
that the price of agricultural
commodities spike.
If you're trying to sell pizza
or pasta or beef, you have
trouble figuring out your
profit and loss.
If you're a business and you
can't predict reasonably your
profit and loss, you have
some big problems.
So in our own backyard,
another multinational
corporation, Bloomberg, summed
up Hurricane Sandy I think
rather nicely.
And this is, again, another
multinational corporation
speaking up very clearly.
And the question is, would you
rather invest in a renewable
grid and mass transit, or spend
$100 billion on recovery
this year, and probably again
in three years, and probably
again in seven years-- if not
in New York, in Miami, in
Atlanta, in San Diego?
These storms will be more
and more frequent.
And this money, it is good money
going after bad unless
we spend our money wisely to
prevent this kind of extreme
weather from being legacy for
not only the next generation--
which it will be--
but prevent it from stopping one
generation hence, we will
continue to bankrupt ourselves,
both financially
and environmentally.
And as I said, I'm going to be
talking about multinationals.
Here's another one, Puma.
Puma's CEO, Jochen Zeitz,
decided he wanted to figure
out what was the real cost of
Puma's business regarding
environmental damages.
And so he worked with
PricewaterhouseCoopers and
Trucost, which is a small
boutique firm, and developed
what they called an
environmental profit and loss.
So what the hell is an
environmental profit and loss?
You never heard of it because
it's never been done before.
They measured water use,
greenhouse gas, land use, air
pollution, waste.
And to their best estimates,
it came to
$193 million for Puma.
So obviously, that's an
estimate and quite an
imperfect number.
But it represents, in fact,
72% of Puma's 2010 profit.
So what does that mean?
It means that if Puma were to
have spent money to either
prevent those damages or paid
for those damages, every other
company in the sportswear
sector would
have made more money.
The biggest polluter would
make the biggest profit.
But Puma, God bless them, they
didn't just wilt from this.
They doubled down.
And now they're doing another
environmental profit and loss
trying to quantify the numbers
better, again doing it with
PricewaterhouseCoopers, and
taking the lesson learned from
the first one and
doubling down.
The parent company, which owns
Stella McCartney, Gucci, Yves
Saint Laurent, is going to do
an environmental profit and
loss across the whole
multinational.
There are other multinationals
embarking on a
similar kind of metric.
And why are these metrics
important?
Well, PepsiCo did something
amazing.
They built a factory in Arizona
a few years ago.
And in that factory, they
created technical creative
engineering like almost
no factory has seen.
It was near net zero energy,
waste, and water--
really spectacular
improvements.
And when the engineer who led
this development was talking
to me about it, I was suitably
admiring because it was pretty
extraordinary.
And I said, so now you're going
to deploy these in all
your factories globally.
And then you're going to share
this technology with others.
He said, well, actually,
I think we'd be
happy to share this.
And we cannot deploy all of it
because if we did, it would be
very expensive.
And it would jack up our
short-term losses.
Within five years, we would have
short-term gains from it
and short-term benefits--
medium term--
five years is medium term.
We would have medium-term
benefits from it
on all of our expenses.
But in the short term,
we would have to
spend too much money.
So we are going to pick and
choose what we will deploy.
So the other thing he said is
that when waste costs what it
should cost, we'll
do everything.
When water costs what it
should cost, we'll do
everything.
When energy costs what it
should cost, we'll do
everything.
This is a case of a company
wanting to do fantastic--
doing fantastic--
work, and because of the rules
of business, being unable to
deploy their fantastic
technologies globally.
These rules got to change.
Just a few more metrics.
In 2008, KPMG, another huge
financial service firm,
measured the cost of
environmental damage caused by
the 3,000 largest public
companies--
$2.15 trillion.
Why is that important
that they did this?
Well, they had the courage,
number one, to antagonize a
lot of their clients, just as
Pricewaterhouse developing
environmental profit and loss
for Puma has clients who are
going, whoa, not sure we want to
have this out in the world.
You think KPMG's clients are
also happy that they have
measured the true cost of
environmental damage?
This is a contributor to a
public conversation on
changing the rules
of business.
And it is a huge piece of global
economic activity.
China measured the cost of its
environmental damages at 3.5%
of its GDP.
So that's what they
said it was.
Anyone want to guess
what it really was?
AUDIENCE: [? 30? ?]
AMY LARKIN: Maybe.
I don't know.
It wasn't 3.5% to be sure.
Pakistan measured it at
6%, Colombia 3.7%.
The World Bank has measured
many countries in Africa.
These damages are real money
paid by real people, real
businesses, real taxpayers,
real families, real school
systems, real water systems.
This is real money.
So it just shows that all money
is not created equal.
If 3 and 1/2% of your GDP is
from environmental damages,
that's not money you want
to be spending.
It's not good money.
Google and Facebook are actually
working in this
realm, in the energy realm.
Obviously, Google, as
I said before, is a
huge player in energy.
I'm sure most of
you know this.
Facebook is now moving
into the field, also.
And you have the option to open
coal-fired energy data
centers everywhere you go.
But I think that your company
has an understanding that
these short-term profits are not
going to be as valuable as
the long-term value created by
developing new renewable
energy systems.
Google, at this point, has over
$1 billion invested in
renewable energy.
So how important is
long-term value?
Who to say it better but Captain
Kirk and Mr. Spock?
This quote is from the fourth
"Star Trek" movie, the one
about the whales.
I presume you all saw it a
few times on an airplane.
But I think one of the
reasons that we love
"Star Trek" so much--
most of us do, at least--
is that within "Star Trek,"
their ambition, which is
extraordinary, is only as strong
as their humility--
their humility towards the laws
of nature, their humility
towards biodiversity,
[? they're ?] even like the
biodiversity of aliens.
I think that our work is to
connect the deepest ambition,
the most profound ambition,
Google-size ambition, with
total humility towards
the laws of nature.
Then we will have a good
cohesion of the laws of nature
and the rules of business.
Sticking with the "Star Trek"
analogy, I have chosen to
create what I would call the
new prime directives.
So I call it "The Nature Means
Business Framework."
The first one is pollution
can no longer be free.
If pollution were no longer be
free, Pepsi's factory would be
deployed by them everywhere
and by everyone else.
The long view must guide
all decision-making and
accounting.
If that were the case, the
people who deforested Thailand
wouldn't do it because it
would be too expensive.
And they would be on the hook
for workers in factories and
corollary businesses in
Kentucky, Singapore, and
Philippines, not only
in Thailand.
And the last one is government
plays a vital role in
catalyzing clean technology
and growth.
In the 1970s and '80s in the US,
Japan was clobbering the
new microchip industry.
And the US government
put together
something called SEMATECH.
And it was a combination
of money, R&D,
cohesion of the industry.
And this led to Silicon
Valley as we know it.
And honestly, no SEMATECH,
no Google.
And I think that this is how
we need to think about what
government can do.
There are actually moments in
history, perhaps not today,
that government has, in fact,
done extraordinary things.
When the United States went
into World War II, within
three months, the auto industry
became the war industry.
I am not recommending doing
that today at all.
But when it is necessary and
there are emergencies, there
are things that government can
do that can change the world.
Our work is also to create the
political will so that our
government actually imagines
itself able to do what it has
to do again.
So these rules offer a new
compass for what is possible.
And so for Google,
I hope that--
I know that you are going to
continue your aggressive,
intelligent, expansion into
renewable energy.
Be bold, bold, bold.
Google uses 0.013% of total
energy usage in the world.
100 searches use about a 60-watt
bulb for a half hour.
I don't know about you, but
100 searches I could do in
seven minutes.
So I'm burning a
lot of energy.
And here I am at your company,
so how can I
not give you a challenge?
I suggest--
I challenge Google, actually--
to join with competitors,
collaborators, clients,
schools, governments to lead a
surge of energy conservation.
Use your platforms, your apps,
your innovation and inspire
global citizenship.
We can blow out 10% of our
energy use in two years.
You are possibly the only
company in the world that
could lead this kind
of effort.
All of us-- you are a verb,
for god's sake--
we can add to the meaning
of what it
means to google something.
To google something could mean
to conserve energy, not just
to use energy.
I'm sure that there are
technological whizzes and
engineers in this room, and
artists that you work with,
and competitors who you probably
don't work with, who
would want to do something
like this.
And on your platforms, you could
encourage the world to
eliminate 10% of our use.
I think that this is possible.
And you can do this.
Imagine that you are working
for a company that has the
power to do this.
That's extraordinary.
So I challenge you to
please do this.
I think that we know that we
have to make a radical
transformation so that our
environmental debt does not
become irreconcilable.
If the oceans fail, which they
might, this debt becomes
irreconcilable.
As I hope that I've shown you,
nothing except for nature can
transform the world as swiftly
as can business, for
better or for worse.
Business must act audaciously
to cohere the rules of
business with the
laws of nature.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AMY LARKIN: Yes?
AUDIENCE: What you call
the environmental debt
[? is what they called ?]
externality in economics.
AMY LARKIN: Yes, it still is.
AUDIENCE: And they've been
talking about taxing pollution
for all this time.
And as far as I can tell, it's
not happening except for a
little bit on the stuff
for acid rain.
Why not?
And why do you think it
could happen now?
I mean, has Congress
gotten any better?
AMY LARKIN: No.
I think it can happen now
largely because there is a
fissure in the business world.
Do you remember in 2009 when the
US Congress was debating
cap and trade?
Yes?
Remember that?
So the US Chamber of
Commerce acted--
lobbied very hard against it at
the behest of, largely, the
fossil fuel companies.
So then what happened?
Apple quit.
Nike, Johnson & Johnson.
A lot of companies stepped
forward and said, you do not
speak for us on this.
You do not speak for us.
And that has not happened
before, where business has
stepped up and said, whoa,
we think there
should be cap and trade.
I have done work with a lot of
multinationals and have been
part of I can't even say how
many conversations where CEOs
and senior management and board
members are, how do we
get this to change?
How do we get the rules to
change so that we are not at a
disadvantage if we do
what we want to do?
Some companies, like Google--
I mean, Google, your company,
is, in fact, investing in
renewable energy.
You don't need to do that.
I mean, I think you do
need to do that.
But you are one of those
companies that has enough
money, enough power, enough
market share, you can do it.
But other companies that are
also big, iconic companies do
not have that freedom.
So I think that the first
reason why I think it's
possible is that there are big
companies ready to step up and
say, we're ready to pay.
We're ready to change.
This cannot continue.
Because we're not going to have
access to water or energy
as we need.
That's the most optimistic
thing that I have seen.
And in the president's climate
change speech a few weeks ago,
he said, we want to start
measuring the
social cost of carbon.
And I hope that he's not talking
about a 10-year, blue
ribbon commission because you
don't have to go very far.
Go to Hurricane Sandy
in our backyard.
That's a social cost
of carbon.
So yes, it is the same as
externalities, except
externalities is a
big old concept.
And environmental debt, I hope,
will become part of
public conversation
about our debt.
I don't want to pay $100 billion
of taxpayer money to
clean up extreme weather, or
another $100 billion to clean
up flood insurance and
crop insurance.
The more people understand
how our debt and our very
fool-hardy environmental actions
are connected, the
faster and stronger we
have the possibility
of making this change.
So that's why I'm optimistic.
AUDIENCE: He's at the
mic, so [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: How do you feel about
working with developing
nations who said, oh sure, you
got develop polluting.
And now it's our turn
to develop and
you're telling us no.
And that's also often where
the most cost-effective
interventions are.
AMY LARKIN: Well, I think
something very interesting
happened recently.
I was working for many, many
years with Greenpeace on
refrigerants.
And HFCs, which are the most
common refrigerants, are also
thousands of times more potent
than CO2 and a growing
terrible wedge in the greenhouse
gas emission
[? load ?] over the world.
And China was always fighting
against the changes to the
rules regarding those
chemicals.
And about six weeks ago or two
months ago, China and the
United States agreed for the
first time in climate talks
that China will join
the US in trying to
eliminate these chemicals.
So I'm, of course, working with
400 corporations who have
committed to eliminate
these chemicals.
But as I have said, the
corporations have led, and now
the governments feel that
it's safe to move in.
I think that it is a hugely
difficult situation where if
everyone in this room never
bought anything again, we'd
probably be fine.
But if people in Brazil or Ghana
or China or India want
to buy a hair dryer or a house
or a refrigerator for the
first time, or whatever it might
be, who are we to say,
well, really, don't?
It is not appropriate
for us to say.
So again, if we create this
connection where things cost
what they should, and where
companies get tax incentives
for doing the right thing--
accelerated depreciation for
green energy investments, for
example; accelerated
depreciation for
state-of-the-art technology
like that Pepsi plant--
there are a variety
of ways to alter--
imagine if our foreign aid were
connected with good clean
technology.
I think that the only way to
realistically deal with this
is for those of us who are
wealthy like we are step up
and say, OK, I get that I've
lived like the king of Egypt
for a long time for really
cheaply and have caused huge
problems globally.
I get that I have to pay.
And I think that this is also,
though, where a Google
platform that shows
we can save--
because in addition to paying
new costs, I think there are
savings to be had.
And I think that we don't
think about them yet.
And when we do that, the entire
course of what things
cost is going to change.
And that should happen over the
next 10 years, not so that
the world goes into total
cataclysmic economic shock,
but so that the world moves into
an economy where the laws
of nature and the rules of
business live together.
That's the only way
to solve this.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
AMY LARKIN: Hi.
AUDIENCE: So love the premise,
love the solutions.
And I think that this is like
a larger systemic issue that
requires lots of leverage points
into the system, one
being changing the rules,
changing policy from the
governmental side and larger
international bodies.
But also a lot of this reminds
me of a larger movement in
triple bottom line
businesses--
certified B Corporations, green
business for America,
things like that.
And I'm wondering if you could
comment on that and how that
might play a larger role.
It seems to be something that's
happening for the last
20 years and only now starting
to get a larger acceleration.
AMY LARKIN: I think that--
AUDIENCE: Can you start by
defining some of those terms?
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah.
Sorry.
AMY LARKIN: Did you
want to do it?
Or you want me to?
AUDIENCE: I'll give
it a quick shot.
So the one that I'm most
familiar with because I'm
working with B Lab, which
is in Philadelphia--
they certify businesses just
like you would for a
fair-trade label or
organic label.
But these businesses hit
certain criteria for
environmental stewardship,
governance, structure, how
they treat their employees,
things like that.
And as a result, it's mainly
intended as a market
identifier to say, hey, this
is not greenwashing.
This is a company that's
actually putting its money and
actions where its mouth
is, and so consumers
can react to that.
But they're also looking at
legislation so that instead of
becoming an LLC or an
incorporation, you can become
a benefit corporation, which has
in its legal charter, hey,
we're going to stick to these
environmental and social
constraints.
AMY LARKIN: And triple bottom
line is the three bottom lines
are people, planet, profits.
And there is a movement similar
to B Corp-- in fact,
probably many of the B Corps
are ascribed to the triple
bottom line.
I think that this is a movement
like the organic food
movement, which has now become a
mainstream movement and is a
large piece--
it's not a large piece,
but it is a growing
and significant piece--
in the world's food supply.
I've had a lot of conversations
like this,
especially with my Greenpeace
colleagues where I'm off
working with multinationals
and come back to meetings.
And you can imagine
the conversations.
So I think that this
is fantastic.
It's a fantastic movement.
And it is the roots of change.
And I think one of the things I
have in my book is a list of
companies that started like
that that are now owned by
large multinationals.
So Ben & Jerry's is
owned by Unilever.
Naked Juice is owned by Pepsi.
Odwalla is owned by Coca-Cola,
Kashi is by Kellogg's.
I could have gotten some
of those wrong.
I apologize if I did.
But it's essentially exactly
those kinds of companies are
being bought by large
multinationals.
So in some cases, I'm sure you
can ascribe motives that are
very tough to why these
companies bought them.
But on the other hand, my
experience is that, in some
cases, the knowledge of these
on-the-ground, longtime,
organic, healthy businesses is
actually flowing up into the
big parent company.
Not all the time, but more
than you would think.
And I think one of the examples
of why this is a--
I think it's great.
And Walmart has committed to--
Walmart--
has got this huge environmental
initiative and
has committed to buying $1
billion from small- and
medium-size farming, and is
now the largest seller of
organic milk and cotton and
other commodities in the US.
Maybe in the world, actually.
Walmart has committed $1
billion to these farms.
Now, whatever you want to say
about Walmart, if I'm a small
farmer, I'm really
happy about that.
Because that allows me to invest
in my business in a way
that I couldn't necessarily do
when a small organic brand
was, in fact, my major
purchaser.
So I think that we
need it all.
I mean, we have so many issues
to address, as you said, from
every kind of entry point.
I love those companies.
They're all my friends.
And I think that the big
multinationals, which can
alter markets more quickly, need
rules so that they can
make money the old-fashioned
way, cleanly.
So that's what I would
say about that.
Anyone else?
OK.
Well, thank you very much.
I really appreciate the
chance to talk to you.
[APPLAUSE]